Okay. We're going to talk about
several different things today,
several different texts. Um, because we're
coming up to the end of the semester,
I often talk about a muffin concluding
with two different lectures that talk
about the rise of institutionalism and
institutionalization of the church,
but I've decided this year
to combine them into one.
So that's why you're reading lists you're
reading for today had some canonical
material, the letters of Ignatius.
You're also asked to read the dedicated,
uh, another non canonical early Christian
writing because I want it to pull
different themes together.
So next time,
the last class of the period of
the course, the last lecture,
I want to then address the kinds of big
questions you might've been having all
semester long,
which is something like how
did this little bitty group
of people following this
unknown Jew in Syria or Palestine in
the first century become this huge world
religion? And what's
the continuity, if any?
Because I've been stressing all in the
whole semester the differences between
contemporary notions about Christianity,
what Christianity is,
what is Orthodox Christianity
for people in our day and age,
what people assume
Christianity's all about.
I've been talking about how that's
very different from the canonical
Christianity that we see
in the New Testament,
and it's even more different from some
of the non-canonical Christianity that
we've seen in things like
the acts of Paul and Thecla.
So next time I will talk about the bigger
issue of the growth of Christianity
from this fledgling little movement and
a few house churches scattered around in
Greek cities and the
eastern Mediterranean.
I'll also talk next time a little about
what is postmodern interpretation of
scripture.
I did talk a bit about the theological
interpretation of scripture and how
that's different from the historical
critical interpretation of scripture that
you're learning in this semester.
If you really want to get into theological
interpretation of scripture, uh,
in an academic environment,
you need to do that through something
like the divinity school or in a seminary,
because that's of course where they're
supposed to be teaching people how to
interpret.
This text for contemporary Christians,
but that's not what we're going
to talk about in this course.
Most of the time I have hinted at that,
but there's also a way of approaching
scripture that might be considered not the
canonical,
traditional way of theological
interpretation and also
not the modernist way of
history of modern historical criticism.
And that's what we might call postmodern
approaches to the text and even to the
text as scripture itself.
So next time I'll address some of those
bigger issues about the new testament
that I've kind of put on
side for the whole semester.
But today that we're taking a first step
toward that because I'm going to look
at some canonical
material in this lecture,
but I'm also going to look at the
letters of Ignatius and the DDA,
k to show you how the church started
becoming institutionalized in ways that
look more familiar to us after
the period of the new, uh,
composition.
How do you create and maintain
unity and a social movement?
That's what early Christian
leaders had to face pretty quickly.
We've already seen that in Paul's letters,
right?
First Corinthian shows a church
that is at odds with itself.
People disagreeing about what the basic
nature of the Gospel is. And Paul writes,
First Corinthians,
in order,
the whole theme of First Corinthians
is you are the United body of Christ.
Now start acting like it.
And so Paul's trying to get a fractured
church to see itself as a United.
There are different ways you can see
this being done. In early Christianity,
Paul of course, didn't have
church structures to appeal to.
Paul couldn't say something like, uh, if
you have a question, go to your bishop.
He also couldn't say, look
at the New Testament. I mean,
he was riding it at the time. There
wasn't anything like that to look at.
So Paul exercise his own
charismatic authority.
By that we mean that in a sort of a
barrier in sociological sense of an
authority that doesn't derive from an a
foreman office from any kind of official
official office that Paul
had. But it derives from
simply his force of character.
So when someone,
uh,
has a leadership position that
derives more from their personality,
their force of character, their ideas,
than it does from an official office,
then that's charismatic authority rather,
uh,
as opposed to an official kind
of institutional authority.
That's what Paul had to do with it.
That's what all the earliest, uh,
leaders of these little house
churches had to deal with.
They had to push their own
ideas of what the church meant,
of what the body of Christ meant,
of what was proper ethics of what
proper interpretation of scripture.
And they had to do it on the strength of
their own character and their force of
personality.
So that was one way that people tried
to create unity in this early fledgling
movement. Gradually, of course,
you have other ways of developing.
Another way of developing a unity that
we see around us the whole time is
hierarchical leadership.
So you have a officer's,
you have people who are either
elected or appointed as officers,
and they controlled unity and enforcing
unity from the top down. We also have a,
and you can see this, therefore,
in modern Christianity,
modern religious movements,
the Roman Catholic Church, uh,
has bishops and cardinals and the pope
and everybody who knows anything about
Roman Catholicism knows that what
the Pope and the cardinals say goes,
or it's supposed to write you.
Uh,
American Roman Catholics and a lot of
northern western European Catholics
sometimes don't go along with
the Vatican on many things.
But the structure of the Roman Catholic
church is intended to help maintain
unity by the means of official
hierarchical leadership structure.
Uh, you also have different
Protestant ways to do this,
which are constitutional kinds of
systems. So when, say, the Presbyterians,
uh, have debates about
whether to ordain homosexuals,
whether to allow gay marriages,
uh, the ordination of women,
which was the debate that really rocked
the Presbyterian church in many of the
churches back in the 1970s, most
of them got over that by now. Now,
the thing that's rocking in his sexuality,
but when they had disagreements,
they go to the general convention,
which occurs every year.
And you have people elected out of
different local churches and parishes and
presbyteries,
they called them the Presbyterian church.
And those people who are
themselves basically elected
from their local churches
and their local presbyteries are
representatives to the general convention.
It looks very much like American politics.
It's not much of an accident.
The American constitution to some
extent is based on what was a more
Presbyterian,
Protestant kind of church polity of having
different houses have representatives
in this sort of thing. So American
denominations, Protestant dominations,
which were growing up at the same time
as different Protestant movements were
growing up and at the same time as
American constitutionalism was growing up,
all influenced each other.
So that's another way to maintain unity
that Protestant churches tend to use.
And then you have other churches in
America that are very free churches.
I grew up in a denomination that didn't
even call itself denomination because it
considered itself simply the church called
the Church of Christ and the Churches
of Christ don't have any national office.
There's no place you can go
anywhere in the world. Uh,
like the rer for most other denominations
that have a national office with
officers and set rules and decide on
him books and decide on Sunday school
materials, there's nothing like
that anywhere in the world.
These churches are all completely
autonomous and a individual to themselves.
They appoint their own officers.
They decide what is doctrine
and what's not doctrine.
They hire and fire their own ministers.
Not even the ministers of these
churches are the highest authorities.
They basically preach and teach,
but they're not the ones who
actually run the churches.
So each individual church,
there are lots of churches
like that in the United States.
There's a lot of baptist churches that
not even part of the Southern Baptist
Convention.
There are lots of free churches and
someone would even have free as part of
their name. Of course, in America,
this is not at all unusual.
Anybody can rent out a storefront and
start their own church and many people
have done so. So these kinds of
churches, it's remarkable that, uh,
that the denomination I grew up in,
although there's no Meta congregational
organization that runs this,
it's amazing how, uh, much, uh,
like they are. When I was a kid,
I would, we'd travel to
Alabama are to, you know,
Maryland or to Saint Louis,
Missouri and you would go to a church of
Christ as long as it said sign and was
one of the same kinds of things
and the services would be the same.
They use the thing, the same
songs. They had the same doctrine.
It's almost like somebody
wrote it all out and said,
this is what you'll do on Sunday morning.
The amazing thing was nobody
had written it all out.
It was just done by the sheer nature of
these churches of being very close knit
and,
and sort of ruling each
other by threatening to
disfellowship you if you didn't
do like everybody else did. So there's
a great amount of cohesiveness. In fact,
I remember being astounded when I was
20 years old and I was in a rock band at
my college and we did a two month
tour for the u s so you know,
playing with milk on military bases
all over in Japan, Taiwan, Okinawa,
Hawaii, the South Pacific,
different places in the Philippines.
And we would actually,
because the college I went to
was a church of Christ college,
we would often visit a church of Christ
in Tokyo or wherever we was in Asia.
And it was amazing. You'd go in and
although everything was in Japanese,
it was exactly like it was back in Texas
and there was no organization forcing
this. It was just the
cohesiveness of the [inaudible],
this socialization of these
different groups. So what we,
what we're seeing going to see today is
the move in early Christianity, the very,
very beginnings of the move from
this freewheeling, charismatic,
structureless kind of organization
structure and authority,
a practice that we see in Paul's letters
and other documents we've looked at so
far, and we're going to see a move
towards more institutionalization.
It's not going to be the,
the Catholic Church yet.
It's not going to be what becomes
a Christianity in the fourth scent,
fourth and fifth centuries when it
does become much more highly organized.
But we're going to start seeing that move.
We see the move a little bit
already in the letter of Jude.
So open your bibles and
look with me at Jude,
the letter of Jude.
It's Jude claims to be
the brother of James.
And scholars think most of the time what
he's trying to do is claim that he's
the brother of James who was the
head of the Jerusalem church.
That is James the brother of
Jesus. So Jube by that, uh, uh,
figuring would also make himself,
uh, the brother of Jesus.
Now this is sort of mark six,
three or Matthew 1355
links these guys together.
What most scholars think
is that this is synonymous.
You won't be surprised now to know that
we don't think the brother of Jesus
actually, or the brother of James
Actually wrote this, a text,
what we know of a Judas who would
have been. Uh, and of course, as I've,
uh,
I think I've explained already,
Jude is simply the Anglo
cessation of the Greek name Judas,
which is simply a Greek version
of the Hebrew named Judah.
So they all refer
basically to the same name.
So Jude Are Judas or Judah.
Uh,
was if he was a brother of Jesus
as the Gospel seem to imply,
then he was an illiterate fishermen.
And we don't think that, uh,
someone with his background with his
lack of education would have been able to
write this letter. So that's the
reason we basically assign it to the,
to pseudonymity
he's dealing with some divisions.
I'm not gonna go through the letter very
much cause I want to move ahead to some
of these other documents. But there's,
there are signs like I talked about with,
uh, first and second Peter last time
that this is a post epistolic letter.
One of those is verse three,
Beloved,
while eagerly preparing to write to
you about the salvation we share,
I find it necessary to
write and to appeal to you,
to contend for the faith that was once
for all entrusted to the saints. So this,
the faith is this thing that was
delivered to the saints at one time. Uh,
he also talks in verse 17
about the Apostles for,
but you beloved must remember
the predictions of the
apostles of our Lord Jesus
for they said to you in the last time,
there will be scoffers indulging
their own ungodly lusts.
So he sees himself
living in the last times,
but he didn't see the apostles living in
the last time. Right. Even though, uh,
Peter and James and John saw
themselves as living in the last time,
he's living far enough after them so
that you can put them in a prior time.
I sort of at the systolic stage of the
church and now he's writing in the last
time.
So this is a post epistolic letter,
but it's also pre canonical. As I said
last time, talking about second Peter,
remember I talked about how second Peter,
the letter of second Peter uses this
letter of Jude as a model for his own
letter and he quotes stuff out
and take stuff out of it. But,
and one of the things those second Peter
did was he took out the stuff that he
found in Jude that was not canonical,
that he didn't figure,
believe there was part of the Real Bible.
But Jude has it in there in verse nine.
But when the Archangel Michael contended
with the devil and disputed about the
body of Moses, and he goes
on and says, what happened?
Well, what does this happen?
Is this in your Bible? Nope,
it's not in your Bible.
Michael never disputed about what to do
with the body of Moses after Moses died,
according to our Bible.
But it is in a Jewish document.
We call the assumption of Moses.
So he's citing a Jewish document
that's not in the Bible that we use.
And it may be that that's why the
second Peter took that reference out.
He didn't want the assumption of Moses
being cited in this text. And he also,
as I said last time,
he cites the some Enoch material.
Uh,
in verses 14 and 15,
it was also about these that Enoch
in the seventh generation from Adam
prophesied saying,
see,
the Lord is coming with 10 thousands
of his holy ones where we have now
literature under the name of Enoch,
which was written probably in
over a period of a few centuries.
It was an accumulation of
several different documents,
but started being written in the third
century BCE and then was added onto in
the centuries after that.
So the,
he cites materials from the
assumption of Moses and Enoch,
which demonstrates that he's still
living in a time when what's considered
scripture by these early followers
of Jesus is still in a state of flux.
So he's not riding at
a time where the Canon,
even the Jewish candidate Hebrew
Bible cannon, uh, has been set yet.
He's also writing at a
time when some of them,
the eucharistic practices may
also be not like they were later.
Look in verse 12,
these are blemishes on your love feast.
You're a got bays
whilst they feast with you or the fear
of feeding themselves and it goes on and
condense the people. These, uh,
got bays probably refer to
the taking of the communion,
the Lord's supper.
But in the context of a bigger meal as
we've seen was the case also in CR and
Corinth.
In First Corinthians 11,
Paul talks about them coming
together and having the meal.
And as part of that meal, they would
have the wine and the bread of the law,
the Lord's supper.
So there he,
repro Jude represents an in between
time in early Christianity that's post
epistolic. So it's not in the
epistolic period as Paul's letters are,
Paul's authentic letters,
but it's also not quite
to the from ecclesiastical
institutions that now for the
rest of today and next time I'll
talk about, uh, become formed the,
you don't have here at this point yet.
Bishops set creeds,
set liturgies and set scripture.
All of those things will later be used
to settle disputes. What did I say?
Bishops,
creeds,
liturgy and scripture.
Those are four things that come to
the used as you might call them,
technologies of unity,
technologies of control in bringing
unity out of this wild diversity of early
Christianity that we've been making a
theme of this course all along the way.
And then the next thing we want to talk
about is the letters of Ignatius because
he then represents another stage in this
process and especially the use of the
office of the bishop itself.
First,
did you notice how much Ignatius makes
himself out to be this great martyr?
He is.
He's a part of his authority derived
simply because he's been arrested and uh,
and he's being taken from Antioch where
he was Bishop to Rome to stand trial and
then to be killed along the way.
He writes these letters when he's going
through Asia minor to different cities
in Asia minor sorta like the, uh,
author of revelation had done.
But notice what he does with,
he plays on the idea that he's
going to die and he makes it,
he makes so much out of it.
Then it becomes pretty much gross.
Look for example at the
letter to the Romans,
if you can find it in your packet.
See, I need to have a Bible
Song for Ignatius is letters,
so we'll know where to find
them toward the last one.
Pardon? Yeah, the letter to
the Romans from Ignatius. Okay,
so look at chapter four
for my part.
I am writing to all the churches and
assuring them that I am truly in earnest
about dying for God. If only you
yourselves put no obstacles in my way.
So he's telling the Romans when I'm
getting trout and put before the beast,
don't you try to intervene and save
me? Don't try to save me. He's saying,
I must implore you to do
me no such untimely. Pray.
Leave me to be a meal
for the beasts for it.
As they who can provide my way to God.
I am his wheat ground.
Find by the lions' teeth to be
made purest bread for Christ,
better still in psych, the creatures
to become a simple performance.
He wants the lions bodies to be his tomb.
Let them not leave the smallest scrap of
my flesh so that I need not be a burden
to anyone after I fall asleep. No, just
up here in the dark. Don't worry about me.
When there is no trace of my body left
for the world to see, then I shushed,
truly be Jesus Christ's
disciples, so intercede with
him. That is with God for me,
that by their instrumentality,
that is the instruments of the lions.
I may be made a sacrifice to God.
However,
I am not issuing orders to you as
though I were a Peter or a Paul.
A little bit of modesty here.
They were apostles.
I'm just a condemned criminal.
They were free men.
I am still a slave though.
If I suffered Jesus Christ will give me
liberty and in him I shall rise again as
a free man for the present.
These chains are schooling me to
have done with earthly desires.
Look at the next chapter,
chapter five about halfway down it's on.
I don't have page numbers here,
but how I look forward,
this becomes almost more
bid people, modern people,
reading nations, his letters,
and he looks like he's Morbid
in his craving for martyrdom.
That's how odd it looks to us.
Modern people,
how I look forward to the real lions
that have been got ready for me.
All I pray is that I
might find them swift.
I'm going to make overtures to them so
that unlike some other wretches whom they
have been to spiritless to touch,
they may divide me with all speed and
if they are still reluctant artist just
show you is forced to them.
He's going to pull the lions' teeth right?
Tortoise chest. You must forgive me,
but I do know what is best for myself.
This is the first stage of
my discipleship and no power,
visible or invisible must grudge me.
My coming to Jesus Christ,
fire crossed beast fighting,
hacking and quartering splintering
a bone and mangling of limb.
Even the pulverizing of my entire body,
let every horrid and diabolical
torment come upon me,
provided only that I can
when my way to Jesus Christ.
This is martyrology stuff,
folks.
This is the beginning of entire cult of
the martyrs in Christianity to become so
important in early Christianity.
And then for hundreds of
years he even now, now,
Paul had also talked about chains, his
chains being, uh, something that was good.
He, he glorified, he gloried in
his chains and being in prison,
Ignatius takes this from Paul and just
runs with it even more. So in Ephesians,
the 11th chapter of Ephesians, the
litter, not appalled to the Ephesians,
but the letter of
Ignatius to the Ephesians.
He talks about his per his
chains as pearls are he in,
in the first chapter of this letter
of Ignatius to wrote to the Romans,
he talks about the chains of Jesus.
And then also I mentioned that he sees
himself though as in his martyrdom,
he will get closer to Jesus.
And in this he's becoming himself.
He calls himself in in the first part
of this, to the, and the second chapter,
the letter to the Romans,
the logos [inaudible] and what do we
know that means we've seen this log off
stuff before,
right?
Transliterated remember,
remember what logos means?
The word correct. [inaudible].
Anybody know I've God.
Ignatius himself is the word of God.
This is what the gospel of John called
Jesus. Jesus was the word of God,
but Ignatius can even claim
for himself the status that he,
especially to his martyrdom
is the word of God. What does,
where does he get all this?
Well,
this is this developing martyrology
kind of ideology and literature.
The idea was,
and most of our Christianity,
when if you're a good Christian people,
when you die,
you won't immediately go to heaven.
It's not like popular thinking
about Christian doctrine.
True Christian doctrine doesn't say that.
You immediately go to
heaven unnecessarily.
It says that you maybe sleep
or do something with your body.
You have to wait for the
resurrection of the body.
It's why when you confess things
like in the Nicene creed popsicle,
you confess the resurrection of the
body of the resurrection of the flesh.
That's because that's in by Christian
doctrinally. That's the true afterlife.
Experience is not the immortal
soul just living forever,
but the resurrection of your
body as a new made body.
But what happens before the resurrection
because we all know that comes at the
end of time. Well, most of the
Christians believed you slept somewhere,
or maybe your soul or your spirit
would go to some kind of halfway house.
This is develops into the,
the notion of of purgatory or some kind
of Haiti's type place or the sleep,
a place where you would either sleep or
you at your soul will go someplace else
and you'd wait for the resurrection. Well,
according to develop Christian ideas,
martyrs didn't have to wait for the
resurrection once they were martyred as a
reward for their martyrdom,
their spirit,
and go straight to heaven to
be with Jesus immediately.
So you bypass some, you know, bad
waiting room type experience. Uh,
if you're martyred,
this became even so important that
people who were condemned to mark to be
martyred but then weren't actually
killed for whatever reason.
Sometimes see people would be condemned
and maybe the beast Jorn hungry that day,
cancel being after thrown to the beast.
They might be turned loose later or
they might be in prison for a while,
or they might have a different governor
who comes along and decides to pardon
people are release them.
So what are you do?
People who are condemned to martyrdom
but not actually martyred? Well,
they were very close to martyrdom.
So that makes them very close to God.
Because remember if martyrs right after
they die, go to heaven to be with Christ.
They're right there in heaven.
And therefore you can kind of pray to
martyrs to intercede with God or Christ
for you because they're in already.
So this idea that martyrs
could be intercessors for
Living Christians develops
and they,
this even carries over to where if you
are condemned to martyrdom but you don't
actually get martyred,
you become what they call a confessor.
And this is because
people can confess to you,
they can confide in you,
that can help you.
So even people who are not
actually martyred that had
been condemned to death at
some point for their faith,
they attained a certain kind of closeness
to God through that activity. And they,
they gained therefore a
certain kind of authority. Now,
this was not an official
ecclesiastical authority.
No institution of the Church granted
these confessors their authority,
but they developed this authority because
people respected them and trusted them.
And so martyr martyr confessors became
somewhat of like charismatic authority
figures in the early church.
Now this caused problems in a few places
because what if you have a bunch of
people going out to some to see some
monk who's now a confessor because he was
condemned to martyrdom but then still
live and they're asking his opinions about
should I eat meat on Friday?
What days of the week should I pray on?
Is it okay to do this and okay,
do that.
And what if the confessor gives a
different answer from the Bishop?
Well,
some people might think the confessor
who's closer to God after all has more
authority than even then the bishop.
Well, bishops don't like this.
Of course they consider themselves the
authority in that location. So you get,
I get sometimes problems of WHO's
the greater authority, the confessor,
the martyr type figure or
the ecclesiastical official
figure of the Bishop.
So notice what Ignatius does with this,
though.
He spends a lot of times in his letters
claiming the authority of a martyr
because he's on his way to being
killed and he says, don't save me,
I want to be killed as a martyr.
But Ignatius also is one of the earliest
people we have in Christianity who
claims great authority
also for himself as bishop.
Now, he wouldn't necessarily have
authority as a bishop over any of the,
but the part of the, he was actually a
bishop. He wasn't the bishop of the world.
He was the bishop of Antioch,
the town in the,
in the east where where Paul and
Barnabas spent a good bit of their time.
So his actual official Ecclesiastical
Authority as Bishop was only an Antioch
and its environs.
So he's playing up his martyrology kind
of authority so that he can exercise a
bit of authority even over these
other churches that he's writing to.
That gives them a little
bit of a reach of authority.
But notice what he does then
with all this bishop stuff.
And here we see the beginnings of the
development of the Catholic church
structure at this very early time.
And this is early because we think that,
you know, Ignatius is writing these
letters around the year one 10.
And if you have this
developing, uh, episcopacy,
that's just the uh,
Greek sort of sounding word for bishop,
our bishop Rick or something like that.
If you had this developing
office of the bishops,
then it that happening at a fairly
early time in a Christianity look.
Therefore at the letter to the tray Lee's
it's right before the
letter to the Romans,
chapters two and three,
your obedience to your bishop
as though he were Jesus Christ.
Wow.
Talk about raising the bishop up shows
me plan the enough that yours is no
Wardley manner of life,
but that of Jesus Christ himself
who gave his life for us,
that faith in his death might save you
from death. At the same time. However,
it is essential that you should never
act independently of the bishop as
evidently you do not. You must also
be no less submissive to your clergy.
Now though,
the Greek word here is presbyters amber.
We've already seen his word come up, which
means elders more literally in Greek.
Now it's starting to be used for
particular kinds of clergy in the church.
So what we'll see is
the bishops
presbyters,
which we'll come to be priest
and remind them of as
apostles of Jesus Christ,
our hope in whom we shall one day be
found if our lives are lived in him,
the deacons to.
So now we have this other office.
We've seen these before,
right? We saw bishops,
presbyters and deacons and bishops in a
certain sense in the pastoral epistles,
but they weren't carefully
formed into a three tiered,
a institution of opposites. Now
we're getting it. And Ignatius,
what will become later basic,
uh,
church structure that lasts up until
the reformation will be bishops on top,
uh, pointed to particular
locations. So the bishop,
we over a city and all the
churches over this city.
And then under that will be priests
who have certain duties. For example,
administering the Eucharist and the mass
and baptizing and under that will be
deacons who have other kinds of duties
in church and they're in that one, two,
three hierarchy.
The deacons to who serve the mysteries
of Jesus Christ must be men universally
approved in every way since they are
not mere dispensers of meat and drink,
but servants of the Church of God and
therefore under obligation to guard
themselves against any slur or amputation
as strictly as they would against fire
itself. Equally. This is paragraph three.
It is for the rest of you to hold the
deacons in as great respect as Jesus
Christ.
Just as you should look upon the bishop
as a type of the father and the clergy
as the epistolic circle forming
his counsel. Notice what we've got.
Then we've got to trinity
almost of offices there are
matched by something like
a trinity of these figures.
God,
the Bishop is the father.
The deacons are Jesus
Christ and the presbyters.
He calls him an episodic council.
What he's doing is he's actually setting
up these offices of the early church to
look kind of like a law court where
you'd have a judge who sat on a,
on a die and you'd have other officials.
So He's imitating Roman official legal
and political governmental structures by
having regional bishops presiding over
a plurality of priests who then are also
over a plurality of deacons
your hand up. Okay. So,
but what makes it really odd
is that he equates, you know,
Jesus the father and apostles
with deacons, bishop and clergy.
And so this is giving them,
this is giving these men in these
offices a great deal of power. In fact,
it's giving them way more power and
authority than most of us historians think
they actually had at this point.
We think we know from other historical
documents that bishops didn't have that
much power until much later.
Presbyters didn't have that
much power til way later.
So Ignatius is trying to pump up
what is actually a fairly new, uh,
structure of authority and a institutional
structure in these. So he does.
He says all the time things like, dude,
don't do anything without the bishop.
He talks about in the letter to the
magnesium [inaudible], paragraph six,
he talks about the Bishops Authority is
the authority of God. The father, uh,
he says in the,
in magnesium letter of Chapter Seven,
the Bishop has to be regarded as the
Lord himself. So what is he doing here?
He's writing these letters to these
different churches and even in fact,
scriptural interpretation.
The main thing about modern Protestantism
is the idea that every Christian is
responsible only to reading of scripture.
Scripture only your responsibility is to
find the will of God through scripture,
through the revelation of scripture.
Ignatius totally disagreed with that.
He says,
there should be no individual
interpretation of scripture
apart from your bishop.
Why? Ignatius knows what
we've all learned ourselves,
that you can make a text mean anything
you want. And as we see from the road,
from Protestantism fracturing up into
a million different denominations and
churches all claiming to
be following the Bible,
you can make the Bible say whatever
you want it to say, and everybody does.
So Ignatius also, he says, you can't
even interpret scripture on your own.
You have to do that in agreement
with the Bishop. So what?
What are we seeing here going on?
We see Christianity,
this fledgling movement
starting to imitate the
structures of the Roman Empire.
It's no longer a bunch of simply house
churches that are loosely federated by
the fact that they send letters back and
forth and have emissaries between them.
It's no longer an authority structure
where Paul simply has to exert his
authority as much as he can through his
own force of will in this charismatic
authority and Claim Authority
as an apostle, although
it doesn't have any paper,
nobody ever gave Paul a diploma that
said, you know, Paul, the apostle is net.
Now an apostle. He couldn't
refer to his, you know,
Princeton seminary theological seminary
diploma to prove that his authority,
he just had depend upon this claim that
he had, that he had seen the risen Jesus,
that he had had this
revelation experience.
So we're moving from that
kind of charismatic exercise
of authority to what is
now much more institutional kinds of
hierarchical structures of authority.
Medieval Christianity would
itself therefore imitate,
uh, the structures of
monarchy and empire. Who,
who elects the pope well in.
And we'll see later that,
uh,
in this period po bishop seemed to have
actually been elected by the people,
or at least by the,
by other presbyters and bishops were
often elected bishops in the modern Roman
Catholic church are not elected by the
people that are appointed by the Vatican
who elects the pope while the cardinals.
So they're, the pope is elected but in,
but by only a limited number of men,
old men who themselves were
appointed by previous popes.
So this is not a democratic system that,
uh,
the Roman Catholic church is structured
on. What does it structured on?
It's structured on a monarchical and
imperial ideas of politics in the ancient
world in the Middle Ages.
So you have an emperor and you have a
pope and they come to hold their power and
remarkably similar ways.
They each have a court,
the emperor or the king has a
quarter of officials that, um,
nights and that sort of thing that
advise him and carry out as well.
The pope has a house of
cardinals and bishops.
The reformation comes along
and decides to change things.
But the referee and the reformers of
course sort of claim that what they were
doing was simply getting back to the
biblical model. That's not really right.
What they were doing was
reflecting what were arising,
bourgeoisie forms of at least a bit
more Republican or democratic political
structures. So Rep, uh,
Protestant churches have their different
kinds of ways of structuring themselves,
which are not free from
political influence either.
They just represent the early modern
political structures that arose as the
bourgeoisie in Europe developed more
and more power and took more powers onto
itself.
So the growth of a mercantile middleclass
and the decline of the aristocracy in
Europe led to more democratic tendencies,
first in towns and then in countries.
Overall,
it led to republicanism the Dutch with
a first to completely get rid of kings
and have a modern republic. And then
of course, the United States becomes,
uh,
the,
the most famous of modern republics in
the beginning and in place of having the
king or the emperor in control.
You're supposed have
constitutional controls,
things that bodies of people come
together to make laws and constitutions,
and then you use that
constitutional control to bring
about unity. Now, of course,
as we've seen in our own modern politics,
you can't always depend
upon the constitutions to
protect you from a certain
rulers, but that's the ideal
reflecting a modern movement.
So that's one of the ways that you see
how Christianity both comes out in the
ancient world,
changes in the medieval period and then
changes it again in the early modern
period.
It's reflecting the changes that are
going on also in politics and society,
which we of course shouldn't
be surprised about.
The other thing that we can
see developing though too is,
and we see this more from the Dda,
k,
the other document I
asked you to read today,
this shift toward trying to
control things like liturgy,
the dedicated,
um,
was discovered in the dedicate
is simply a Greek word.
It means the teaching.
Because this document purports to be
the teaching of the 12 apostles. Now,
it wasn't actually written by the 12
apostles. It was written much later.
It may have been written around the
same time that the letters of Ignatius,
most people place it around
the turn of the first century.
So around the year 100 or
a little bit after that,
it's called the teaching
of the 12 apostles. It's,
and it's the first time we get an
Christian literature is something like a
manual on how to do it. Here's how
you're supposed to do a worship service.
Here's how you're
supposed to do a baptism.
Here's how you're supposed to
do the Eucharist or the mass.
Here's what authority structures you have.
It was discovered in 1873 so really only,
you know it's fairly modern,
is a very modern discovery,
didn't exist from the ancient period
for Oregon analogies as far as we know.
It was discovered in a monastery
in Istanbul, Constantinople,
that is now Istanbul.
So the importance of the discovery
of this document was Ken is hard to
overestimate because it's just a great,
great document for an early period of
seeing how did Christians actually do
their liturgy.
It's very dependent upon the gospel of
Matthew and the letter of James in the
New Testament.
It shows a lot of things like that.
It's also dependent upon certain Greek
philosophical and Hellenistic Jewish
ideas. But now let's just look
at some of the things that says,
look on paragraph seven
chapter seven of the DDA. K
We get hints about how early Christians
did baptisms from different places.
We think most of the time that
it was an earliest period,
not splunking a water or are
dipping a little water on something,
but putting people all
the way under the water.
We also get hints maybe that they had
people do it at night and they had it.
People do it naked. So you took off your
clothes, you went down into the water,
you were baptized,
you came up and they'd put a white
robe or something else on you.
So we have a few hints about this,
but this is one of the,
this is the earliest time we have
anything like these instructions.
It says now about baptism.
This is how to baptize,
give public instruction on all these
points, and then baptize in running water.
Notice he wants you to,
it's extra as living water and the Greek.
But what he means is try to baptize in
a river or something that has actual
running water and not instill water if
you can in the name of the father and of
the son and the Holy Spirit.
So you have trinitarian
formula as part of the baptism.
If you do not have running water,
baptized in some other,
if you cannot in cold than in warm. So
they had to be bad Tizen, Coldwater. Yep.
Uh,
before the baptism or over at the one
who baptized into one being baptist most
fast. So you have fasting ahead
of time and any others who can,
and you must tell the one being baptized
to fast for one or two days beforehand.
And then he goes into fasting. Here's how
you, here's how you're supposed to fast.
You're supposed to fast on, um, uh,
three times a day and other prey. Now
this is the prayer. I can't see it here.
Oh yeah. Uh, you, you're fast must not be
identical with those of the hypocrites.
They fast on Mondays and Thursdays,
but you should fast on Wednesdays and
Fridays. Well, who are the hypocrites?
Probably Jews.
He's probably trying to say,
I don't want you Christians to fast on
the same fast days of the week that Jews
are fasting on, so he gives them other
days to fast. Notice what he says.
He gives the Lord's prayer,
which is familiar to most modern people.
Our Father in heaven, hallowed
be your name. Your kingdom come,
your will be done on earth as in heaven.
Give us today our bread for the morrow.
Forgive us our debts as we forgive our
debtors. Do not lead us into temptation,
but save us from the evil one for yours
is the power and the glory forever.
That sounds a lot like the Lord's prayer
that you yourself may often say in
church if you ever go to church,
but if you, if you notice carefully,
this prayer is actually more like what
most modern Christians pray in church
then is either the version of the
Lord's prayer in Matthew or Luke.
In other words,
he's closer to what we actually prayed
today than either the prayer version in
Matthew or Luke,
which is a very interesting fact in
itself that our prayer comes more from a
tradition that's closer to the
DDA, Kay, than it is to the Bible.
Notice he gives instructions
on the Eucharist.
One of the interesting things is
if you go to a church nowadays,
usually what they do is they blessed the
bread first and then the cup of wine.
He actually has it the other way around.
He says,
you give the cup first and then the bread,
you have first prayers of thanksgiving,
and it's this word Thanksgiving that
we actually get the term Eucharist.
If that just comes from the
Greek word Thanksgiving, uh,
if you go to different
Christian denominations,
they'll call this differently.
Some places call it the Lord's supper.
Some people call it just the communion.
And if you and some churches,
especially episcopal churches,
we'll call it the Eucharist. In Catholic
churches, he used to call it the mass,
but they're all referring
basically to the same thing.
There's the sharing of the bread and the
wine. So he gives instructions on that.
Uh, he also noticed says the Eucharist
is to be restricted to only baptized
Christians so you don't give the bread
and the wine to people who are not
baptized.
Then he gives some prescribed prayers
in chapter 10 and it's interesting.
He's now we're not in a time where people
are just allowed to pray any away they
want to. He actually gives written prayers
that there that he wants them to use.
Again, don't exaggerate. This guy's
control. Whoever's writing this, we don't,
we don't believe that this document was
actually controlling behavior of all
Christmas at this time.
He's trying to bring about some unity
and conformity and a time that we,
historians assume there was
still a huge amount of diversity,
but by publishing this document and
telling people even how to pray,
he's trying to bring about this kind
of unity in chapter 14 it's interesting
because it gives the different events
that would take place on the Lord's Day.
That is Sunday. For example,
you're supposed to have confession.
You confess your sins.
You're supposed to reconcile with anybody
that you're not in agreement with.
And then you have the Eucharist, which
he talks about as a sacrifice. So by now,
Paul had never talked about sort of uh,
the Lord's supper as being
something like a sacrifice.
And later Christianity,
it will be considered something like a
sacrifice when then, so that's why the,
you can only have a priest do it because
it actually changes the elements and
something's real is going on there.
So the Eucharist has by this time started
becoming considered something like a
sacrifice for Christians who don't have
any other form of sacrifice, right?
Because Christians don't go around
sacrificing lamb or any lambs or anything
else.
And then you have different leaders.
He has in chapter 11
roles for apostles and,
but he also has roles for profits.
Notice what he said in chapter 11.
I think this is really interesting.
This is a time when there seems
to be regular sorts of officers,
but then there are these non sort
of regular officers. Where am I?
Oh
yeah.
Okay.
Now about the apostles and prophets
act in line with the Gospel precept.
Welcome every apostle on arriving,
arriving as if he were the Lord.
But he must not stay beyond one
day in case of necessity. However,
the next day too,
if he stays three days,
he has a false prophet on departing and
apostle must not accept anything safe,
sufficient food to carry him till his
next lodging. If he asked for money,
he's a false prophet. So just kind of
mixing these Word Apostle and prophet.
Remember Apostle just means one who is
sent out in Greek boy he's talking about
are roving prophet who go around to
different churches and it is really
introduced as you know,
let him stay with you two or three days.
If he's going to stay longer than that,
he's gonna have to start
working for his bread.
And if you have a prophet who
says, hmm, I'm getting a message,
I'm getting a message. Oh yeah, you're
supposed to give me $5. Jesus. So
then you know he's a false
prophet and you kick them out.
So it's a nice way to figure out what
your genuine profits in which were false
prophets.
If this were followed in,
most modern Christianity
would have a lot of false,
not on TV.
Unfortunately it doesn't
work in modern Christianity.
So we have a lot of false prophets
on TV asking for a lot of money.
So there's also in chapter 12,
this is not just true for profits.
He talks about how to treat
other travelers. So this,
the churches are becoming
something almost like hotels,
which is makes sense because
in the ancient world there
aren't really very many
hotels. You couldn't just, you know, check
in at the motel six. So the Holiday Inn,
when you're traveling around,
you have to stay with friends.
There are a few taverns,
yes, some brothels,
but they're not very safe and that
they're very unsafe and they're not
respectable places for a good person to
stay, uh, their houses of ill repute.
And so what do you do if you're a good,
respectable Christian and you want all
of your other fellow Christians know that
you haven't been sleeping around, uh,
when you're on your business trip? Well,
you have to either stay with friends or
now increasingly you can stay with the
church.
But he says,
if you have these travelers who come in
and they want to stay more than two or
three days, then they have to get a job.
They had to start supporting themselves.
So you see him developing this
church as a networked organization.
Again,
we have more and more organization
coming into play here that has d defined,
uh,
offices and some others that aren't
so well defined like these traveling
profits,
which he's trying to regularize.
So he's trying to give rules for an
institution of the profit because that
itself is not an institutional kind
of office in early Christianity.
So with Ignatius and with the [inaudible],
we've moved along way from this tiny
little band of followers of a Jewish
apocalyptic prophet named
Jesus of Nazareth. In fact,
we've even moved a good ways away from
the informal charismatic kind of House
Churches planted by the Apostle Paul,
right?
We're now seeing the institution.
We've not yet arrived at what
will become Christianity.
That is with all the
trappings of late antiquity,
full church structures, creeds, doctrines,
social networks, monasticism. This'll
be a big thing that starts developing,
especially in the third,
fourth and fifth century,
the rise of monasticism as another form
of Christianity that provides a very
important structure for it that will
last all the way through the medieval
period. We don't have that
yet. We don't have a canon yet.
We don't have a canon even though the old
testament Muslims or the new testament
yet, but we see developing in the letters
of Ignatius and in the DDA DTK the
beginnings of this later development
into what will come in more mature
Christianity.
The move from that late
Antique Christianity though
say to the Christianity of
the fourth century when
we get the major creeds,
like the Nicene creed and the creed of
Eden to modern Christianity and it being
what we call a world religion
is itself centuries away though,
and I'll talk about that next time.
What we've done this whole semester is
barely scratched the surface though of
what would be the history of Christianity
and the main point of the scratching
has been to get you to see
that at the very beginning,
the first 100 years of
this Christian movement,
because that's basically all we've
covered, and not all that either,
but the basic first 100 years,
this was not anything like the
religion it came to be. It was diverse.
It was widely different
across geographic areas.
It had lots of different doctrines.
There wasn't anything called
orthodoxy yet and Harrison yet.
That all develops later, but it's,
this is the very beginnings of it.
Any questions,
comments or outburst?
Okay,
I'll see you next time.
We will also hand out the final paper
instructions next time in class.